yeah hello guys welcome to this
broadcast I hope you are enjoying the
Dame and looking forward to that to that
show of us okay let's kick off with some
blitz chess as we do every Monday
haven't played any games today so
looking forward to some quick quick
games we got questions what kind of
questions do we have are there black
people in Germany or what do you think
of course got all kinds of nationality
Sam okay wow I'm below 2,300 what did I
do to my rating that doesn't look good
playing Walpole I think I should win
some games and get rid of that rating
yeah hello to all all of you greeted me
in the chat a [ __ ] goblin and magic 79
just developing here against this brick
path scampered this is my my set up
there I would like to go be three hmm oh
I just go forth Bishop e3 it's also okay
Bishop e3 Queen d2 is also perfectly
fine b3 was a bit tough to play with the
long diagonal always being an issue but
this is this is totally okay here maybe
I should have played f3 let's do that
now make sure that no Knight g4 is
hitting hmm well
let's threaten Bishop c5 it's a bit it's
not very subtle but still not bad yeah
blacks problem is the knight on d5 it's
just a very good very good piece and you
don't want to place his six sd-6 then is
totally weak okay um cheb g5 maybe I
also have f4 f4 f5 it's also not bad but
okay I go Bishop g5 him there's a
question if I did see the lackawanna
nakamura gamba Nakamura they did Oleg us
in the rook were this Bishop endgame and
yeah I did see that but I don't consider
this in any way unsportsmanlike because
it's increment and I mean if not if
Caruana defense a defense but he's got
the increment and he has to has to has
to just play this is a good thing about
increment chest you just have to play
chess yeah you have to have to prove
that you can draw that and you have the
time to prove it and my camera on played
on perfectly okay okay zette nation says
good afternoon from Pennsylvania yeah I
good afternoon to Pennsylvania and he
says he likes my book that's cool thanks
okay here i can't go Bishop c5 and win
the Queen I think I would do that think
I won't do that d takes Knight f6 check
if it takes on d5 I have Bishop p6 yeah
i know my chest friends this is your
most catchphrase i'm not using that I
don't want to steal other people other
people scratch people's no other people
catchphrases someone requests that i
play a phone yeah I can play I can play
the audio for today so f four nights you
for don't want that yeah the c-4 point
is hanging but I can take here right and
the text c5 it's not so easy for him to
to cover that maybe it doesn't need to
always covering attack that okay no f1
hello to alien j 1220 nice to be a SS
yep I'm glad that I got some spectators
here or some viewers um so if i take on
g4 go h3 bishop is six f5 that looks
pretty dangerous immediate f 593 it's
probably still okay yeah i think i'm
taking i can go f5 now let's go by five
mmm I sorry my poon my porn see people I
don't understand your question I'm sorry
okay I think this should win material I
will know the back rank hmm I just
blundered bad the back rank he can take
on at five I didn't see it that's its
lucky that was my idea of course but he
could have taken an f5 I what is the
worst chess book hard to tell there are
a couple of really bad books around one
of the worst opening chess books that i
recently read was is called the sniper
that is something i bought that book and
well at the time I didn't really think
about putting it on ebay maybe I should
have done that as it was I got that book
at the beginning of the week and a
couple of days later I met friends Sam
and we discussed that well here you know
I've got this book and what do you think
and that okay this is rubbish and I sort
this book to a friend to a friend form
just just a bi am I just wanted to get
rid of that damn book this is damn awful
yeah it's g6 repertoire it's pretty bad
it just is full of mistakes and and
weird recommendation yeah Latvian gambit
I grand master guide I don't think that
this yeah I fell to be as kind of
appropriate anything more felt felt
wrong okay so we have this this dragon
here by a transposition it wasn't really
what I wanted to do but yeah somehow
it's turned out to be a dragon
yeah probably that beer was good enough
to make sure I forget most of the things
that I had to read in the book it was
just a total mess full of weird analysis
and what is especially whatever what
what tells you especially that the book
is not good is that if they continuously
if you know are the best lines I mean
yeah you have a very often you have some
kind of idea what the critical line in
opening is and if the author is just
never getting to the critical line you
know it's not it's no good I mean he
just never really looked at the lines
that that mattered okay speaking of
things that matter myeeeeh porn does
matter quite a bit hmm not good it's
really a bad position here I wonder
maybe I can go a five giveaway e75
instead but it's not it's not good
yeah i can go King evade maybe I should
King evade but Queen d2 looks kind of
awkward yeah let's try that yes the the
Leningrad is not a bad idea if you want
the Dutch language it's not a bad idea
if you want some kind of Universal
weapon against t4 stand openings if you
like the positions it's really not for
everybody but it's a it has this
universal character that it gives it
some peel okay so I wonder I cannot
check well maybe I can take you five I
mean the rook is hanging but I'm really
left with many weak bones I think I'd
rather open this good book for the
Scandinavian defense hmm yeah there are
a couple of books but i don't really i
mean there's a there's a wide range of
scandinavian lines yeah the book by
Bauer is probably okay for queen d 5 for
25 lines but there's also them now that
the book buyer bye-bye grandmasters
Smerdon about the Scandinavian with
Knight f6
so I'm a pawn down but I have a decent
dark square blockade for the moment yeah
this is this is the problem a little bit
he's attacking before and it's difficult
difficult to play around that
hmm how do I play this not really sure
it just said it's not really good this
is the real issue I mean it's not so
easy for y to make any headway at least
I mean not super easy just marking time
yeah I'm not no big expert on books on
the Scandinavian now I never considered
this opening seriously I mean it's
perfectly okay just that I never really
thought that I should should play it
thing is it's it's it's not really so
suitable for a surprise weapon because
you should know your stuff
I don't I think you can probably start
at a very young age in teaching the
charlson chest snow don't think there's
a particular particular limit or
anything yeah he's playing well I guess
maybe I put the night on c5 and ended in
trying to exploit a moment where I can
activate my queen if here is some
weakening his position a little bit too
much he have 94 right or not what kind
of move is that Queen have six what am i
overlooking here see if I ever would
this is checkmate Wow
um so let's see it yeah the Scandinavian
with Queen d6 certainly playable yeah I
watched a little bit but of that car
Nakamura car wanna match was very good
entertainment always like to watch clean
some high-level blitz yeah definitely
this is a question that everybody can
answer with yes baby elephant ass do you
think you'd be a better player if you
started chess earlier than younger than
when you did yeah this is true for
everybody starting early is very helpful
so got a sloth defense I'm not so sure
about the Queen 26 can you name in this
era book I don't know I wanted to play
you for I'm sorry I simply simply forgot
about it it's um yeah it's just routine
yeah I always play d4 93 and so on maybe
I should have cheek and there I mean
okay that position is nice for white
anyway it's not so easy for black to
free himself
my idea is to always try to prevent the
c5 move if that if I'm succeeding and
that my position should be a little bit
better so let's see if I can manage that
have you Roxy one seems difficult for
wider place you five yeah here
interesting acting all night c5 I have
played games like that I maybe you can
take on c5 of courses has played in a
split second they never consider
important decisions like that in any any
kind of with any kind of scrutiny okay i
can check here not sure that this helps
i will have an excellent compensation
anyway ok let's take i have not watched
them the the football match on Friday on
friday i wasn't all so it didn't really
pay much attention to what happened in
Paris I was watching the the Nakamura
Kerwin i mentioned bit relax and only
later learned what happened
ok so I do 97 here
yeah miss Bishop 1c8 it's not exactly
exactly fantastic so let's go rookie one
yeah he's got problems with this bishop
for example hoopty one rookie one okay
that could couldn't this might be a good
move Drago just before I do I'd take
okay let's take let's play before he
maybe has maybe as a five or something
like that maybe the other I never
considered to play the Scandinavian in a
in a serious way not that it is bad but
I feel it's tough to play this opening
as a pure surprise weapon because you
can if you don't know what you're doing
you're probably not doing very well so
you have to invest some time and I never
felt that it is such such a great
opening that I should invest time in it
so here yeah I mean looks kind of nice
for white but I wants to go bishops is
six so probably have to go like this so
that i can take a sick son Bishop c6
am I upon down I know I didn't really
count i think i paid more attention to
some strategic considerations here okay
if i go they are it's difficult
difficult to win really how can i try to
win here my rook rook should invade
somehow maybe like this night be three
Roxy five yeah the Greenfeld is the raid
opening but it's it's not easy to learn
it's it's it's lots lots of concrete
complicated lines that you need to study
I'm try to to activate the rook here
if I get route straight I can play this
for win pretty comfortably look to c 6
something like that it's not so easy for
for him so Luke him see going for some
count to play I don't know what is he
doing ok he just gives me that pawn and
then he wants to go look g8 or what is
the idea I'm covering this wow he allows
me to play g3 that's crazy went where
does he give me that g3 move for free
surprising ya know might be porn looks
very dangerous maybe I should have taken
the bishop now that I think of it
Oh Bishop a 6 mm hmm that sets
unfortunate really high I could have
played that better could have played
that much much better so how to do this
night be five or how do i go to e5 I
don't know only got 40 seconds left I
don't get to see 5 unfortunately would
be immensely helpful check here will be
here to go to a 720 something seconds
hmm ok you switch to time play mode
hmm okay
okay can just about to catch the pawn
I've trapped my own night I've trapped
my own night yeah of course he just
plays on time doesn't try to find good
moose
I got two seconds great yeah no I'm
totally winning but I'm losing on time
against this guy yeah okay yeah I was
just too low I just too slow oh my god
yeah i just i just took far too long he
committed a complete suicide in this
game by playing some really atrocious
moves like Age 3 but ok just too slow ok
i send so many messages it said it's
tough to tough to have to follow okay so
okay this is the my way is going with
the my way line Bishop everything Bishop
c5 is bad um yeah so let's see what
happens as a question what must I what
what my favorite subject in school was
that's easy history was owned by fire
actually
yeah a book on bullet chest that's
probably a pretty short read right
so what does he try to do castling long
now maybe maybe white can cancel long
ship takes pawn takes that's probably
not so not so one bad which part of the
game to focus on as a 1900 feeder player
yeah the typical recommendation is
tactics and I'm sticking with that
because what tactics is just a way of
describing the being precise and
calculating variations and this is the
most important skill in chess by far you
have to calculate variations as
precisely as possible and as quickly as
possible and if you are not good at that
you can do whatever you want you're
never going to win any chess games and
with being a good calculator you can
compensate many many weaknesses and
overcompensate in fact many weaknesses
even if you have no no particular idea
about chess but if you're avail if you
can calculate lines and well it just
yeah makes all the difference see form
hmm night before or something or just
yeah well he can take on c6 play Bishop
before maybe okay let's go back here
an FAQ video yes I was thinking I was
thinking about some ama on reddit and
like answer collect the questions in on
reddit and answers in the answer them in
a video yeah d Google slides to the
shock on how I schoenberg ashwin back
shirring back probably it is right I
have to look into that book yeah one
good thing is that here mr. my way from
Norway he takes a long time okay maybe I
can arrest him with the a poor Nia
quickly decided
yeah math doc asked what about a 1600
rapin rep repet 1500 blitz and 2000 and
tactics trainer hmm yeah I think I mean
there are always things that you can do
it's also not a bad idea totally bad
idea if you're like 1,900 okay this is a
different guy I'm sorry there was
someone with 1,900 reading last what to
do I mean with 1,900 writing you can
actually consider to do some opening
study it's not not a terrible idea it
shouldn't be the main focus of your
studies but you can look at openings of
course I mean this is often yeah it's
often yeah demonized in a way I don't do
openings at all if you are on this in
that level and so on I mean it's not a
bad idea to look at some openings you
should you should just not overdo it
yeah it should be just a part of your
your training if you don't don't do it
too much it's perfectly okay so what's
now especially it's helpful to them to
look them to liquor look at the openings
in the content in the context of
complete games not just look at a couple
of moves and say okay why does better or
so but let's say you want to play a
particular opening and try to find out
who's playing this opening what kind of
players I experts and then try to
understand how they play the particular
line and what ideas they have and so on
and then you learn something about
middle games yeah this is the thing if
you study the opening correctly and by
looking at complete games you can yeah
you can really gain good understanding
on how particular position types have to
be boom have to be played okay that
being said I cannot move my pieces
hmm that's no good I didn't play that
well at all I have no idea how to
untangle here thinking 94 but you just
prevented that cannot move my pieces
here night a six maybe can I it looks
pretty awful
fallout 4 was released someone says and
therefore we have less viewers is that
the case I didn't check he didn't check
the view count yeah i don't think i will
play the game i'm not i mean in general
i like the bethesda games i mean i play
a plate sky ring Skyrim like a complete
edict but i'm more of a yam let's say
fantasy type of role playing person i
don't like that kind of that kind of
scenario fall out that much mmm yo he
wants to go g 497 Bishop p6 what a
dreadful position it's really awful
I didn't play morrowind i only it
started to look at those games when
oblivion was released and playing moral
winton now nowadays it's a little bit
it's a little bit strange because there
no graphics and so on there's so much
below what is standard nowadays it's a
little bit difficult to now play it yeah
yeah yeah yeah now he's killing me and
after this terrible opening my why Jets
always always hated to lose against
super bad opening play but it's not all
it's not all there is of course it's not
I mean maybe I can put up some fight
okay it's not that easy I can draw now I
think I probably should draw unless he
tries to win I wonder I cannot try to
win with rupee aid maybe I said
completely come on let's try that it's
not completely bonkers if I get those
pawns here meet
that's made I'm very lucky very lucky
okay I've never never played never
played final fantasy games then never
played gothic then I don't really in
recent years I mean I don't play that
much games no he said a good game
finding good nice finish um yeah I'm
just not playing very well but ok I will
go if ride with white now I always I
always here come on here we go I go that
I go with the Kings gambit against this
it's difficult to play something really
sharp maybe play some some funky line
here d takes 90 for 97 96 checkmate it's
that good we need to as a very weird
line I'm 41 someone asked about my age
so we have a French defense basically
now with my queen being on e2 that's a
bit strange but anyway will be
interesting now I didn't catch the
Bafana mew sharda match was interesting
i think at the same time there was the
Nakamura kawana match and also who you
found was this Neji was pretty
interesting they had some some good
fights there
yeah so John did win that match I was
thinking he is a slight favorite to win
not by much but a little bit but he was
it a slight favorite of the same okay I
couldn't take d4 yeah unfortunately my
idea is very simple taken take a bishop
and win okay that was funny money for
okay yeah I always recommend one year
five to begin us against 24 it's the
best move to teach you important
important principles like development
and so on but it's not something that is
mean it's not mandatory you can play all
kinds of openings so what to do here
against Rayo maze can I get the gruene
felt I recently tomorrow III how boring
can you be mr. Freya wow he really plays
the most boring stuff ever amazing
okay so how do you play now it's already
pretty nice for black maybe I can
provoke a three and then drop back to e6
I'm slightly better here because of his
bad development but it's not it's
nothing great okay you form yeah he's
right before he can go Bishop e3 now it
should be okay for white what is why
it's called him does he really just want
to trade everything down to a draw it
really looks like it if I go queen bee
to now um he goes Queen d8 Bishop f8
bishop age six is that the keys I think
it is huh I can defend with 97 but it
looks very risky okay as I gots read
display that end game yeah it looks kind
of okay but how do we do anything here
probably tough to do yeah it seems a
little bit like the worst version of
warning us some some early better
version maybe let their left in the
Brazilian jungle or something like that
okay i was expecting them to take i mean
it's a terrible move but i was still
hoping you would do it
ok I'm quite sure where I went to go I
think here maybe I saw that Queen King
be three can be answered by 95 I wonder
about 95 any way I can also take now
it's a bit of a strange decision but I
can go be five
home yeah should I take on c3 or not
interesting question and then fix the
porn on light squares it's a bit of a
strange decision and not not really
necessary at the moment if I go b5 now
that's not going to be good
I want to see what he's doing I'm not
quite sure what his plan is his plan is
to play render moves quickly okay night
c5 is not doing anything yeah there's
simply nothing going on this is the
problem and I try to do something which
is which is often costing me okay come
on I'll take this and see what happens
it's probably not a good idea now that I
think of it hmm King coming King coming
to a fire what am I doing here
what a bad idea to take that was a very
bad idea mmm that was just a bad idea
King see for now yeah it's very easy for
him to play that's the problem ah
terrible decision to take them it wasn't
so terrible when I was still having the
idea to play b5 myself but um
yeah I mean it's a draw I guess but it's
not really comfortable with the time
taking g for a night f3
I would totally love to deliver some
kind of silly check me to him probably
that's not going to work
and I have to take the draw not much
that I can do have to take the draw
after all yeah and we draw at least at
least I gotta draw out of it I was a it
was the edges Tara a plate that really
badly I just played bad him taking that
night oh my god some wiki opening hmm
what is Becky I mean if they go d43 on
me it will be difficult to do something
yeah I noticed the webcam is kind of bad
I don't know what it is I really don't
know the reason i try to to change some
some setup but it didn't didn't help oh
ok i'm sorry i have to play the maracas
see this is kind of my dream opening so
ok
yeah this is this is what I would love
to have in every white game probably
would never use the game anymore at
least in tournament jasmine White has
excellent control over the position and
black has got very little in terms of
counter plane okay um 95 here or not hmm
he can't eat and play 94 business that's
not good maybe night yeah I guess an IP
5 yeah that's not the fun kind of Dragon
the kind of throw the kitchen's think
dragon but this is the kind of wins most
games dragon for white and I like those
so I think I can just take now Bishop
just maybe I should have nerve ok it's
ok so this one yeah it's probably not
that much i have to admit would love to
play a for somehow let you fall I one
doesn't help are you three okay i think
i'll just keep the position i just keep
it as it is and see what he's doing
five
hmm good move it's a good move can't
can't do much ef5 is really strongly in
this position with the simplified oops
with the simplified nature of everything
and five makes perfect sense
okay so what you see doing shooting for
Bishop t4 to see one to go back to f6
yeah it's a very it's very dry very dry
yeah I don't mind that too much I was
thinking that maybe a four can be a
target in this position like a three aha
interesting so he wants to move that
night what be three be three basic going
with this night chief for know hmm ok so
what is he were to see up to I don't get
it don't get this idea
night he wants to go Bishop b2 I guess
ok
so don't see how he handles this a three
Pawn situation now yeah someone says
he's got a second be three yeah that's
true this is an idea but I don't see how
it's going to work now therefore as a
funny move but I have King f2 shouldn't
be very very some
night c 2 is also in the mix to pick up
that pawn my structure is not great but
I mean everything on light squares but
if i get the pawn I don't care aha so he
wants to try to sacrifice but it doesn't
work my night is stopping the a porn
very dry dry stuff but the bond is a
bond is a bond is a bond okay so boom
trading now yeah otherwise I probably
don't win the porn so unfortunately have
to trade this okay I have to bring the
King up so need to be precise with this
I think probably night over here on the
on the light squares or maybe just go
back yep if I get in before it would be
noise but here Scott King c5 now that
will be difficult as the breaking c-5m
I have to have to push him back somehow
with some some 94 probably now it should
be a win I don't think he can defend
this it looks good and I've got some
extra minutes that's good or extra
seconds okay so nitey form and now yeah
night over there to g4 provoke this pawn
maybe i don't know i don't have that
much time on the clock I know I can take
it I can take it just like that
yeah nights are worse than bishops but
they can they can give those nasty night
folks always always tricky and it is not
it's not catching my night okay I cannot
secure g4g five or maybe King here King
up King up is good are we close to the
one-hour mark already or is funny to see
how time flies in those streams okay so
g5 or how do I do that ok let's go g5
no I just have to have seconds it's not
good okay so one on time okay so one
more game one more game Magoo OGB FM
from cameroon cameroon the others this
is these are the other the Lions right
cameroon's lions okay can I do something
sharp let's go over the Kings Indian um
yeah general i do like classical music
but not something i mean i'm not a big
expert but in general i like it i mean
not Eve i'm not even a small expert to
be honest I what's the like a bit of
opera it's it's it's good oops he took
with the e porn I was essentially pre
moving Bishop g4
okay please go back that looks fine I
think he's wasting lots of time there
and doesn't doesn't seem too yeah to
effective at five I go g5 yeah maybe I
check this with before yeah i'm not a
fan of cuffed react I mean there are
okay but it's not like I would I would
listen to that
Bishop b3 is funny I will sacrifice the
exchange then rookie 394 Bishop g4 Queen
each form that's pretty strong okay so
here Queen invasion where I could be 5
i'm going to try to destroy that that
pawn that porn center there I don't
believe with his non-existent
development that he can do much about it
now or no Sh lager please yeah b5 what
are you doing now mr. Magoo
check is super busy tonight here pretty
cool
and are you disconnected or something
he's not okay yeah i'm more of a metal
guy i mean even though it's a long time
since I'm woody checked what's out there
yeah so what is this is going to play
some B 3 on I mean maybe you can take
and hope that I take d 5 which I'm not
planning to do I played that really
quickly yeah yeah shout out shout out to
Basel yeah I'm doing it again of course
you're back in the day I was more of a
Metallica guy
but I heard different various i heard i
listened to various types of metal but
it's been a while its really user in a
while okay so what is he doing here like
h4 or something yeah that looks that
looks interesting I can just take the
five and then and be that porn up if I
go G for Queen f4 that looks looks a bit
fishy now let's be let's just take that
pawn it's probably probably okay and now
that I think of it if he takes on g5 I
probably have queen deform it might be
better than just training Queens
yeah I think kiss are so performing I
mean you you wouldn't believe what what
kind of funny funny bands are still
around I mean they simply a all need
money to maintain the lifestyle he's
amazingly slow here this guy I mean I'm
like three minutes up on the clock which
is pretty remarkable considering that
I'm not that quick usually so what is
this so you're basically giving me the
whole everything here right hmm probably
I could have played that better even
know that I think of it anyway it's an
exchange yeah anti resides so yeah so I
gained like 40 points in that screen
that is nice yeah I didn't play well
that's Court has got some points um so
are there any urgent question someone
suggests medawar for music yes they're
fun I still think it's fun I mean that
they're utterly crazy but it's always
fun try the men-of-war drinking game
whenever they say one of their typical
words like like steel or hail or
whatever you always have to drink drink
a beer or something good good stuff okay
anyway I hope you like the show it was
fun I liked it a lot playing some funny
blitz games and gaining some points in
the hi-c five-minute pool okay let's
meet next week again thanks guys